mesdames et messieurs de chez un ami à
mon tour je veux d'abord remercier notre
secrétaire général eric woerth pour son
travail un cyclope vice président
isabelle le callennec parce que comme
isabelle comme je pas d'ennuis jeu aussi
remercier notre trésorerie alors je suis
sincère alors merci à tous ceux qui ont
participé à cette à ces tables rondes de
diamants animé par par claude avec marc
philippe edouard eric merci à arnaud
robinet valérie de bord catherine drolet
qui portent des responsabilités des uns
et les autres merci à bernard accoyer
parce que les responsabilités qui ont
été les siennes que tu acceptes de
participer comme cela ça témoigne de ton
attache par la famille je sais que tout
ce qui concerne la santé en particulier
et la protection sociale en général tu
le suis de très près merci marianne
merci tous ceux qui ont donné de leur
temps alors je vais pas redire ce qui a
été dit qu'est ce qu'on veut faire
d'abord nous possédons l'un des modèles
sociales les plus généreux au monde et
nous sommes les héritiers directs
puisque cette général de gaulle de ceux
qui ont créé la sécurité sociale je crie
choses soient claires entre nous
la sécurité sociale à la française fait
partie est un élément de notre
civilisation
ici en france
cher michel cher jean pierre non nous ne
sommes pas les états unis on vous
demande pas votre carte de crédit avant
de vous opérer ici en france
moi j'aime les états unis c'est pas pour
critiquer c'est simplement pour mettre
les points sur les i
parce que les républicains on s'adresse
à tous les français
on ne s'adresse pas une catégorie de
français cherchons tous les français ici
quand la vie vous fait un coup dur et la
vie ne fait que des coups durs pour ceux
qui ont peu d'expérience ceux qui
pensent que la vie est un long chemin
tranquille bonne chance pour le futur
quand la vie vous fait un coup dur quand
vous êtes malade ça vous tombe dessus
quand vous perdez votre emploi parce que
le signe ferme et que vous n'y êtes pour
rien quand la crise du monde entier
s'abat sur la société française et vous
brise
ici on vous laisse pas tomber et je veux
dire parce que c'est ce que je pense au
plus profond de moi même
il n'est pas question de remettre en
cause
l'expression de cette solidarité il ya
des décennies derrière j'ai vu qu'ils
aiment beaucoup les états unis quand tu
es la crise de 2008
il ya des classes moyennes qui se
retrouver littéralement à la rue du jour
au lendemain
alors il ya le dynamisme des états unis
ya la force des états unis il ya
beaucoup de choses dont nous devons nous
inspirer
mais ici quand la maladie vous tombe
dessus on vous le soigne quand la vie
vous brise on vous tend la main et je
souhaite que ça reste comme ça c'est une
question de civilisation
ça n'a rien à voir avec le débat très
utile un eric les deux eric sur la
fraude sur l'assistanat c'est simplement
que je ne veux pas qu'il y ait la
moindre ambiguïté entre les français et
nous la sécurité sociale fait partie de
notre acquis
de notre bilan puisque c'est pas la
gauche qui la voulait c'est le général
de gaulle et non seulement nous devons
défendre cet acquis mais nous devons en
être fiers
alors à partir de ce moment à partir de
ce point on doit faire preuve de
lucidité qu'est ce qui se passe la vie
la france en 2016 n'a rien à voir avec
la france de 1945
sa sé on peut dire les choses comme ça
tranquillement la vie s'est allongée
la flemme la famille est toujours aussi
précieuse dans le coeur des français
mais l'a profondément évoluer la façon
de vivre sa retraite elle a changé
puisque la retraite je vis en deux
phases une première phase active
consacré pour certains boulots de
complément aux loisirs aux petits
enfants et puis une deuxième partie on
dirait un quatrième ou cinquième âge
avec des problèmes de santé et des
problèmes de dépendances on peut dire
cela qui n'existait pas en tout cas dans
cette proportion
bon les parcours professionnels n'ont
plus rien à voir
la médecine chez un professeur chergui a
profondément changé les progrès de la
médecine
j'ai écouté comme je suis né qui était
quand même pas le moyen-âge 1955 ne rit
pas comme ça qu l'autre à finir par
devenir désagréable
et bien en 1955 la péridurale cher
bernard
enfin je veux pas dire je suis très
incompétents mais une femme qui
accouchait souffrait et il ne venait à
l'idée de personne de dire qu'un
accouchement été sans douleur enfin je
regarde les souvenirs dans ma famille
c'était comme ça aujourd'hui
et tant mieux femmes qui accouchent sans
péridurale ont dit-on maritain bourreau
dans nos médecins eu un accident
maxillaire moi quand j'allais enfin j'ai
pas du tout pour que je vous raconte sam
20 ans quand j'allais chez le dentiste
ça faisait mal
aujourd'hui un dentiste qui nous fait
mal changé de dentiste quoi le le
rapport normal
derrière cherfi plat la plaisanterie le
le rapport à la médecine à la douleur ou
confort a profondément changé et nous
nous trouvons aujourd'hui avec un
chômage mance
alors quand je notre système social a
été inventé un métier en plein emploi on
a 33 on a presque 34 % de parts de de
dépenses sociales dans le pib
ces 28 % en allemagne depuis la fin des
années 50 le montant des dépenses
sociales en france a doublé alors là
aussi je précisais une chose il n'est
pas question pour nous de réduire les
dépenses de santé
mais on augmente les dépenses de loisirs
tant mieux enfin on va pas dire que
notre politique c'est de réduire les
dépenses pour notre santé alors que
chacun d'entre nous est préoccupé de la
santé de sa famille quand même appris il
ya deux cent cinquante mille personnes
chaque année qu'un cancer en plus et
250000 personnes qui ont alzheimer en
plus chaque année
moi je pète à la tête d'une formation
politique qui dit mon objectif c'est de
dépenser mois pour la santé
ça n'a pas de sens enfin qu'est ce qu'on
a de plus précieux notre santé la
question c'est de savoir est-ce qu'on a
les moyens de payer
est-ce que cet argent comme et dans la
santé et bien l'utiliser
voilà donc si dans ce cadre là que nous
allons poser notre projet sur la gauche
est assez facile leur bilan les déficits
y en a plus pour l'hôpital 400 millions
en 2014 de déficit
vraisemblablement on dépassera les 500
millions en 2015 sur les professions de
santé
c'est le grand chelem de l'erreur manuel
valls a convoqué une conférence de santé
en février 2016 conférence de santé qui
étaient postérieurs au vote de la joie
de rennes c'est une grande nouveauté
dans notre démocratie
on conserve après avoir voté la loi ça
n'avait encore jamais été tenté ils ont
osé et d'ailleurs réussi aucune des
organisations de médecins n'est venu il
est vrai que c'est assez cocasse d'aller
demander leur avis aux gens sur quelque
chose qui est déjà beauté bon alors je
rappelle que durant mon quinquennat
nous avons investi 8 milliards d'euros
dans les hôpitaux
et nous avons demandé les personnels
médicaux qui le méritent et bernard
dhaussy pour ça avec les infirmières qui
sont passés en catégorie à qui était une
demande depuis bien longtemps
je dis pas ça par question d'ego je dis
ça parce que nous avons fait un effort
pour l'hôpital public qui avait rarement
été fait le bilan de la gauche
humoristique on a donné le pouvoir à
l'assurance maladie de décider de ce qui
était un bénéfice raisonnable pour les
hôpitaux et les cliniques privées
je dois dire
que demander l'avis de l'assurance
maladie pour analyser les bénéfices
raisonnable des autres ça serait drôle
si ça n'était dramatique
voilà donc qu'après avoir utilisé la
direction du travail pour sanctionner
les quatre qui travaillait trop dans les
entreprises voilà qu'on utilise
l'assurance maladie pour poursuivre les
cliniques privées qui font des bénéfices
quand on dit que la france marche sur la
tête
on a quand même un certain nombre
d'éléments
durant mon quinquennat l'hôpital a été
la priorité
je pense que la priorité pour le
quinquennat qui vient sera la médecine
libérale c'est qu'une idée très forte
que nous voulons poser
nous devons réhabiliter la médecine ou
bien alors ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que la désaffection pour
les professions de santé est un problème
considérable si nous avons l'une des
meilleures médecine du monde sebastian
médecine libérale
la médecine libérale va nous amener au
nom de sa défense à refuser absolument
et à abroger instantanément cette idée
folle du tiers payant généralisé
c'est une idée folle parce qu'elle
laisse à penser que la santé est
gratuite
ce qui est vraiment une idée bizarre
elle déresponsabilise le patient elle
est inutile parce que les français à la
cmu bénéficie du tiers payant généralisé
et surtout je vous rendre attentifs à
cela le tiers payant généralisé ça veut
dire que les médecins n'auront plus
qu'un seul client
l'assurance maladie c'est donc
l'assurance maladie qui imposera aux
médecins le traitement pour vos
pathologie et s'en sera fini de la
liberté de prescription pour le médecin
et c'est l'assurance maladie qui
imposera aux patients le choix du
médecin dans le quartier qui est le
vôtre
et s'en sera fini de la liberté de choix
des médecins par le patient voilà
pourquoi nous abrogerons instantanément
le tiers payant généralisé alors pour la
médecine libérale devine vingt quatre
axes de réformes
la premier league est extrêmement
important complément du tiers payant
généralisé c'est rendre du temps médical
aux médecins
les médecins ont 15 % de leur temps
occupé à des tâches administratives ce
n'est plus possible
qui a jamais vu dans sa vie un
formulaire pour faire rentrer ses
parents dans une maison de retraite n'a
jamais vu ce que l'administration et sa
complexité peut produire de plus
horrible je mets au défi qui que ce soit
de remplir lui même le document c'est
impossible
c'est la raison pour laquelle tant de
patients vont voir leur médecin en leur
disant rendez nos services est ce que au
bout et remplir ce document illisible à
l'ère du numérique
on ne peut pas perdre un temps précieux
en paperasserie
nous aurons donc la priorité rendent ce
temps du temps aux médecins pour faire
ce qu'ils savent faire
j'ajoute que ça conduit à repenser toute
la chaîne de santé les médecins doit
faire le travail de médecins les
infirmières ne doivent pas être
mobilisés pour faire la toilette des
patients fin je ne dis pas ça du tout en
disant que c'est facile je dis qu'on
peut utiliser les infirmières notamment
dans le cadre du développement de ce que
nous souhaitons
l'hospitalisation à domicile sur des
actes je pense les dialyses les
chimiothérapies un certain nombre de
soins on est quand même plus confortable
quand ça vous tombe dessus quand on est
chez soi plutôt qu'être été
à l'hôpital je voudrais dire dans le
parcours de choyer les pharmaciens je
plaide pour que certains vaccins puis 7
fait aussi dans le cadre de l'activité
des pharmacies et je pointé du doigt ce
que voulait madame touraine autoriser
les ventes de médicaments dans les
grandes surfaces
mais la stratégie des grandes surfaces
c'est baisser les prix pour vendre plus
je croyais que la politique de santé
publique
c'était de consommer moins et de
consommer mieux allez comprendre quelque
chose à ce qu'il vous présente
deuxième proposition de ces plans
médecine libérale algérie c'est un point
très sensible mais il faut regarder en
face c'est là la revalorisation de la
rémunération des médecins
bon je suis le dernier à avoir
revalorisé la consultation rappelez-vous
les 22,23 euros quand on est bac +10
excusez moi quand vous avez explique un
patient qu'il est atteint d'une maladie
grave comme 10 et 23 euros on voit le
décalage absolue entre la l'égalitarisme
et la réalité de la difficulté de ce
qu'on a dit en même temps quand il
s'agit de recevoir quelqu'un pour le
faire son ordonnance pour la poursuite
d'un traitement sur le cholestérol
je vous dis il n'y a aucun rapport entre
la consultation qui annonce une
pathologie maladie grave et le
renouvellement d'un traitement donc moi
je suis attaché nous sommes attachés à
la rémunération à l'acte mais nous
voulons affirmer qu'il ne peut pas y
avoir que la rémunération à l'acte
il ya d'autres éléments qui doivent être
pris en cause en compte par exemple
est-ce qu'on peut pas imaginer un
forfait de rémunération pour une maladie
de longue durée
est ce qu'on ne peut pas rémunérés sur
des objectifs de santé publique
quand les médecins s'engagent dans la
prévention et dans la santé publique
je pense que suivre un diabétique au
long cours je suis pas sûr que le
paiement à l'acte 6
thématique sur la bonne solution qu'un
forfait peut-être mieux adaptée donc
nous poserons la question de la
rémunération des médecins dans le sens
de leur revalorisation
alors qu'on me dise pas qu'on les
médecins pour l'argent c'est pas la
question
enfin alain vers ce qu'on arrête de dire
que parce qu'on est passionné par son
métier qu'on compte pas ses heures on
doit pas être rémunéré 1 il ya un
équilibre entre les deux entre présenter
les médecins qui sont des gens
passionnés comme intéressé par l'argent
ou expliqué que les conditions
matérielles d'exercice de sa profession
ça compte pas il ya peut-être un
équilibre qui s'appelle le l'été la
bonne foi peut être le bon sens
troisième élément c'est une question
très difficile prioritaire pour nous la
lutte contre les déserts médicaux
il ya des pans entiers de notre
territoire il ya plus de médecins ou les
médecins partent à la retraite sans même
trouver quelqu'un pour racheter leur
patientèle selon là alors je voudrais
que nous fermions une porte qui est la
porte de la coercition
moi je pense qu'on ne peut pas obliger
un médecin d'aller exercer dans un
endroit où il n'a pas envie d'exercer
bernard du voile non mais d'abord un
médecin je souffrais moi aussi je
souffre parce que je déteste s'exercer
dans cette ville et dans cet endroit bon
ça commence mal je ne suis pas sûr que
ça soit la meilleure formule dans ma
famille à des gens qu'ils croient nous
nous voulons fermer la porte à ça ça n'a
pas de sens non alors qu'est ce qui a du
sens je les dis à peyrens jeune
policière
là aussi il s'agit pas de dire que tout
est une question d'argent mais je pense
profondément qu'un médecin qui accepte
d'aller exercer dans une région dans une
ville qui est un désert médical iran en
plus de la prestation qui fait un
service public
il est donc normal que soient rémunérés
davantage le même hâte dans un lieu de
désert médical que dans
un lieu de pléthore médicale il me
semble que dire cela c'est inciter et
c'est du bon sens parce que sinon on va
voir des parties entières du territoire
100 personnes je pense exactement la
même chose
voyez-vous pour certaines de vos
spécialités parce que on observe quoi
qu'on n'a pas à ma connaissance de
grands problèmes pour trouver des
dermatologues je les en félicite et je
vais me fâcher avec personne mais enfin
des obstétriciens des urgentistes des
gynécologues toutes les spécialités qui
ont des grandes contraintes dans la vie
personnelle sont un peu déserté
si elle est professionnelle qui vont ils
doivent aussi en être récompensé qu'est
ce qu'on veut une médecine de qualité
avec toutes les spécialités dont on a
besoin également répartis sur le
territoire
il me semble que nous devons tenir
compte comme nous tiendrons compte
également de la formation des médecins
parce qu'évidemment un jeune qui passent
dix ans sur dix ans de formation qui on
passe neuf années et demi à l'hôpital
encore une fois je peux dire demande de
l'hôpital mais développe un regard sur
sa carrière qui est forcément orienté
sur l'hôpital plus que sur l'exercice en
cabinet d'une médecine générale or la
médecine c'est aussi l'humain la qualité
du diagnostic le la capacité d écoute de
la patientèle l'amour qu'on peut avoir
pour un métier on se sent tellement
important dans le regard des autres
je veux dire que la médecine n'est pas
réduite à l'hôpital même si l'hôpital
est un élément essentiel
enfin quatrième proposition pour ce plan
médecine libérale 2020 je souhaite que
nous acceptions de prendre ce que
j'appellerais le virage ambulatoire
je m'explique est là dessus parce que je
crois que au moment où il ya tant de
nouvelles technologies nous devons
adapter la formation des médecins ou
enjeux du système de santé de la même
façon que 90% des personnes âgées
restent souhaitent rester chez elles
plutôt que d'aller dans une maison je
suis sûr que 98 % des patients soit être
soignés chez eux plutôt qu'à l'hôpital
si c'est possible alors on a un hôpital
qui déborde de tous les côtés parce qu'à
trop demande aux urgences il ya trop de
monde dans les lits de long séjour
il faut absolument qu'on prenne le
virage de l'ambulatoire je reviens pas
sur ce que j'ai dit claude surtout le
personnel de santé les infirmières
notamment pour désengorger l'hôpital
pour renforcer la médecine libérale
parce que l'ambulatoire naturellement
c'est la médecine libérale qui va
l'organiser et pour renforcer le confort
des patients
je m'incline qui a été une fois dans sa
vie quels que soient les efforts pour
les hôpitaux les cliniques dans une
salle où les patients sont en
chimiothérapie avec des perfusions la
glace
sur la tête non c'est la vie on veut
dire moi je refuse pas parler de ça
c'est un ça peut vous tomber dessus à
tout le monde chacun d'entre vous peut
avoir un membre de sa famille qui est
touché par tout cela et ça fait du bien
ça ouvre les yeux d'accompagner les gens
maintenant parce qu'on voit c'est pas
des la théorie ce dont on parle c'est de
la vie c'est de l'humain et pas moi je
pense que si on peut avoir le même
traitement chez soi avec le médecin qui
bien que vous connaissez ou l'infirmière
qui vient mon intention salon ça mais de
l'humanité
on a une société qui a besoin d'humanité
voilà je voudrais quand même rappeler ça
qu'on parle de tout ça c'est pas
simplement de l'argent c'est pas
simplement des concepts c'est plus
humain ça peut tomber sur tout le monde
mais moi je souhaite que ce virage
ambulatoire soit pris parce qu'il est
extrêmement important alors un mot
maintenant pour l'hôpital fait un beau
et tellement à dire d'abord l'hôpital je
veux leur rappeler
c'est le moment aiguës de la maladie
il faut quand même qu'on arrête de
vouloir faire faire à tous les mêmes
choses l'hôpital c'est le moment aigus
avant c'est pas l'hôpital
après c'est pas l'hôpital l'hôpital
s'est exceptionnellement important au
moment aiguës de la maladie alors nous
proposons une véritable révolution des
établissements de santé autonome nous
voulons faire avec l'hôpital ce que nous
avons fait avec l'université faire le
choix de l'autonomie
le soin de l'autonomie cela veut dire
que les hôpitaux auront le choix de
leurs spécialités de leur organisation
des heures de travail des rémunérations
deux conditions à cette autonomie un
engagement d' équilibre financier
et deuxièmement la signature d'un
contrat entre la rs et l'hôpital moi je
pense que l'autonomie sadr est une
proposition faite à tous les
établissements
après il la saisissent ou la saisissent
pas c'est un autre problème
alors on me dit ah vous a fait un
système de santé à deux vitesses
bah écoutez ici on peut tirer tout le
monde vers le haut j'ai eu le même
argument sur les universités eh bien moi
je crois que ça permet une loi de
gresham à l'envers la loi de gresham
c'est la mauvaise monnaie qui chasse la
bonne l'autonomie c'est les pauses
établissement qui tire tout le monde
vers le haut
faire confiance responsabiliser donner
la possibilité de gérer sur l'hôpital et
de le développer
il me semble c'est important dans un
autre cadre edouard qu'on n'oublie pas
c'est dans notre esprit l
hospitalisation publique et une
hospitalisation privée
nous avons besoin des deux nous refusons
l'uniformisation et cette espèce de
détestation du secteur privé qui amène
beaucoup à la médecine notamment sur la
définition des prix de revient
parce que si nous n'avions pas
l'hospitalisation privée on aurait
beaucoup plus de mal à définir ce que
c'est qu'un prix de revient les
cliniques privées font partie du service
public de santé comme les établissements
publics
nous avons besoin des deux et nous ne
supportons pas cette mise en cause
permanente un mot pour rassembler les
deux nous voulons c'est une grande
ambition réconciliait la médecine
libérale et l'hôpital fameux problème
fameux débat
combien de médecins parfois craignent
d'envoyer leurs patients l'hôpital de
peur de pas leur dôme et non écoutés sur
thur dans cette salle ça se pose pas nos
vins blancs ou comme vous transmettent
pas le dossier alors nous faisons une
proposition c'est que nous
réfléchissions à la question des
urgences on ne reviendra pas à l'époque
où les médecins venaient au domicile des
patients
il y en a qui continuent à le faire
bravo enfin l'idée que tous les médecins
comme d'un montant à partir de 5 heures
le soir passé à la maison dans la
tournée je suis pas sûr qu'on retrouvera
avant longtemps
ce système et en même temps je ne crois
pas qu'on arrivera à convaincre les
familles
quant à 3 heures du matin l'enfant mal
au ventre moins violents maux de tête
aucun problème d'aller directement
service des urgences comment on peut
concilier les choses eh bien il me
semble qu'on devrait travailler c'est la
proposition que nous faisons sur un
double service d'urgence les urgences
vitales qui sont incontestablement les
urgences de l'hôpital on est renversé
sur la voie publique
il faut intervenir immédiatement et des
urgences de soins d'urgence pour
reprendre son expression chère claude
avec une possibilités d'orientation les
urgences vitales c'est l'hôpital
seraient l'hôpital et les urgences de
soins d'urgence le panaris tous les maux
de tête d'un enfant ne sont pas
synonymes de gravité tous les maux de
vente ne sont pas synonymes de
péritonite de risques et on aurait dans
chaque hôpital autonome une possibilité
d'avoir un service d'urgence géré par
l'hôpital et à l'intérieur ceux ci avait
urgence une urgence avec des médecins
libéraux qui prendraient en charge non
pas comme hôpital mais comme médecin
libéral de garde
l'urgence de soins d'urgence c'est à
dire vous voyez ce que je veux dire
elle qui n'est pas vital on aurait ainsi
réussi à désengorger les urgences de
l'hôpital à rapprocher les médecins
libéraux de l'hôpital et à garantir aux
français aux patients l'aco l'hôpital
c'est toujours le lieu où ils aiment
aller mais dans un hôpital on peut
rencontrer des médecins hospitaliers ou
des médecins libéraux
selon la gravité de la pathologie ou du
problème qui est le vôtre voilà la
proposition que nous faisons elle me
semble imaginatif et de nature à
rassembler demain
alors pour terminer irait tant d'autres
choses à dire
jacques chirac avait eu la très bonne
idée de lancer le plan cancer
c'était une tellement bonne idée que je
l' ai repris pour un plan cancer 2 et
que à mon tour j'ai voulu plan alzheimer
il faut dire match à bernard que mon ami
de 300 millions de recherches wazemmes
c'est pas faire insu aux chercheurs il
faut du temps on n'a pas trouvé ma
connaissance
bernard on a avancé sur la connaissance
de ces fameuses plaques brut qui se
porte dans le cerveau on n'a pas trouvé
le médicament qui permettent donc notre
idée c'est d'abord d'utiliser l'europe
parce que je ne vois pas pourquoi on
devrait chercher dans notre coin avec
les italiens qui cherche dans le leur
les allemands dans le leur et les
anglais dans leurs passes que les
souffrances est exactement la même et la
maladie la même je pense qu'il va
falloir continuer là-dessus
notre idée c'est de développer des
continuer bien sûr sur toutes ces
maladies neurodégénératives mais nous
voudrions que soient mieux prises en
compte
ce qu'on appelle les maladies psychiques
qui ont été gravement sous-estimé pas ce
qui excusez moi quand on est
schizophrène ou bipolaires ou qu'on a un
vrai burn out et qu'on vous dit il faut
te secouer
c'est comme si quelqu'un qui a la jambe
cassée on lui dit tu devrais t'inscrire
au marathon de new york
je parle pas des simulations je parle
des vrais c'est peut-être que dans
toutes les femmes et vous connaissez ça
parce que la dépression la vraie le
suicide excusez moi qui est la première
cause de mortalité chez les jeunes
ces maladies là pendant très longtemps
elles ont été sous-estimés comme
l'autisme d'ailleurs qui est un drame
pour les familles et pour lequel nous
avons un grand retard je voudrais qu'on
mette le paquet là-dessus parce que je
pense que c'est extrêmement important
comme d'ailleurs les forts qu'on doit
continuer à mettre en oeuvre pour les
gens qui sont atteints d'une maladie
incurable
notre conception de l'humanisme c'est un
malade incurable doit pouvoir mourir
dignement la dignité
c'est le moment le plus important de
notre vie notre mort avec renaissance on
puisse le vivre dignement et je voudrais
qu'on développe les lits de soins
palliatifs
je les avais doublé et ce sont en
général les parents pauvres parce que
naturellement on préfère investir pour
guérir mais mes chers amis nous les
républicains nous devons porter aussi ce
message que la mort on doit pouvoir
l'aborder dans la dignité et les soins
palliatifs
je souhaite qu'on fasse une priorité
j'avais été bouleversé par un jeune
couple lui m'avait dit sa femme avait
passé deux mois dans un centre de soins
palliatifs
mehdi grâce à ce centre ma femme a pu
mourir dignement trente trois ans il y
avait 2000 lits 2000 on les a portés à
4000 faut continuer
et je pense que une société voyez-vous
s'honore pas simplement d'être
compétitive pas simplement d'être
innovante pas simplement de d'investir
dans la haute technologie société
elle est une civilisation quand elle est
capable d'investir pour des gens qui
n'ont plus rien à attendre qui sont en
fin de vie mais qu'on doit traiter
dignement et je le pense pour les
malades comme je le pense pour les
personnes âgées alors 7 milliards de
déficit l'année dernière comment va-t-on
faire
d'abord notre idée c'est de nous servir
la prochaine élection présidentielle
pour avoir un mandat des français
nous avions réformer les retraites
60 à 62 ans je rappelle que cette
réforme nous l'avons réussi 22 milliards
de recettes en plus pour la sécurité
pour l'assurance vieillesse sans qu'il y
ait un seul blessé dans la manifestation
et 149 3 et ce en pagaille
ce proverbe quand je me suis tu je
m'inquiète quand je me compare je me
rassure on tourne la page de la retraite
à 60 ans qui était pas facile c'est pas
facile c'est plus facile de promettre la
retraite à 60 ans que de la mettre à 62
pas de pagaille
pas de violence pas de 49 3 aujourd'hui
la loi comme au lycée rien grâce à
surveiller en ahl 49,3 et grâce à ce jeu
rien à l'anarchie voilà la différence
entre un quinquennat
pardon emmène alors valérie et claude 63
ans départ la retraite en 2020 64 en
eric woerth a été ministre qu'à porter
cette réforme avec un courage et une
intelligence remarquable
l'idée
c'est vrai l'idée c'est que la
présidentielle soit un mandat la
présidentielle permira de trancher ce
sujet tout dire avant pour tout faire un
vrai comme ça n'aura pas y revenir
ça sera clair transparent et honnête à
peu près tout le contraire de ce que
nous voyons maintenant alors s'agissant
de des personnes dépendantes
notre idée c'est la suivante on en a
beaucoup parlé il ya des différences de
vues entre nos d'ailleurs il faut le
reconnaître
elles sont pas dramatiques isabelle
c'est la vie et c'était des sujets
tellement complexes qu'on peut en
débattre et qu'on peut même assumé des
désaccords en gros qu'est-ce qu'on veut
d'abord que les gens puissent rester
chez eux
ça veut dire développer les emplois
familiaux supprimer les charges sur les
emplois familiaux là à caen généralisée
ensuite comment on peignent les
départements vous êtes dans une
situation épouvantable
financièrement le des risques de
dépendances c'est pas un des sujets les
familles aujourd'hui notamment les
classes moyennes se trouvent eric
gautier président édouard du président
aussi un département dans une situation
épouvantable
parce qu'on considère que le reste à
payer pour une famille d'avoir quelqu'un
en situation de grande dépendance c'est
qu'un sens à 2000 euros par mois qui
vous reste alors en même temps la 7
milliards de déficit de l'assurance
maladie
comment on fait notre idée c'est
d'encourager les familles jeudi d'
encourager à s'assurer pour le risque
dépendance
alors je sais qu'il est un grand débat
mariam est ce qu'on fait le cinquième
risque ou pas notre idée c'est déjà
d'améliorer la prise en charge
fiscal d'une cotisation volontaire
d'assurance pour la dépendance
après tous mes chers amis on s'assure
pour notre retraite
il n'est pas absurde qu'on puisse
s'assurer pour le risque dépendance
savez vous que sur 100 % des lycéens
d'aujourd'hui
il y en a la moitié la moitié qui sont
centenaires donc la question du risque
des programmes devient malheureusement
une quasi certitude compte tenu de
l'allongement de la durée de vie alors
est-ce qu'il faudra le moment venu voir
une prestation pour aider ces familles
on peut en débattre on n'a pas voulu
trancher le débat maintenant mais la
question est posée je le reconnais bien
volontiers parce que les appartements
sont devenus plus petit parce que les
enfants n'habitent pas touche dans la
ville des parents et qu'on n'est pas
forcément un enfant indigne parce qu'on
peut pas prendre chez soi un père ou une
mère devenus dépendants
compte tenu de la taille des
appartements du fait que les femmes
travaillent et heureusement
du fait de la vie qui fait que beaucoup
de femmes élèvent seules leurs enfants
si en plus on doit s'occuper des parents
mais bien sur la solidarité familiale
north nationale d'haïti familiale 1
quand les parents vivent à saint-etienne
et que les enfants travaillent à lille
comment il faut donc nous proposons de
renforcer la défiscalisation pour
l'assurance volontaire travaillera dès
que des systèmes d'assurance mutualiste
est haute et on laisse ouverte la
question eric de l'éventualité on n'a
pas voulu trancher ça s'agissant du
handicap parce que c'est lié je dois
rappeler que nous avions pris un
engagement celui d'augmenter de 25%
l'allocation adulte handicapé cet
engagement a été tenu
malgré la crise quand le monde s'est
effondré où tout le monde m'a demandé de
renoncer à leur revalorisation de
l'allocation adulte handicapé on l'a
tenu bon parce que j'estime que le
handicap ça peut vous arriver à tous
le handicap c'est quoi c'est pas de
chance à la naissance ou pas de chance
pendant la vie eux ils ont vraiment
la solidarité quand vous êtes sur un
fauteuil quand vous avez une maladie
rare quand vous le trouvez avec un
enfant trisomique
vous êtes bien obligé de compter sur la
solidarité qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait
pour l'endiguer qu'est ce qui s'est
passé depuis cinq ans rien des mots
alors je tiens beaucoup au normandy cas
mais je voudrais avec tout mon
engagement dire qu'il faut privilégier
l'efficacité au discours est à la norme
moi je préfère dans une de vos villes
cher daniel aucun gosse handicapés nous
reste en dehors de l'école mais c'est
pas pour ça qu'il faut qu'on vous
demande que toutes vos écoles est un
ascenseur calibré pour prendre un
fauteuil dans les logements sociaux
c'est le comble de l'absurdité on a
maintenant des salles demain de 12
mètres carrés avec des chants pour
enfants de 6 parce que toutes les salles
de bains doivent être aux normes du
fauteuil mais je préférais de bons coups
qui est 10 ou 15 % des appartements
qu'ils soient aux normes handicapés et
qui soit vraiment rien réservé pour nos
compatriotes qui ont un handicap et qui
en ont besoin
plutôt que de faire 100% de deux
d'appartements aux normes handicap avec
des handicapés qui par ailleurs ne
peuvent pas avoir accès à des
appartements qui en vérité ne leur sont
pas réservés je pense qu'il faut
accepter cette idée que je vous rappelle
que ces six millions de personnes de nos
compatriotes 6 millions qui sont touchés
par le handicap
alors pour terminer vraiment je dirais
qu'un mot des problèmes d'emploi qui ont
été très bien évoqué par marc philippe
parent eric ciotti et par eric woerth
je vais simplement dire une chose là
dessus
là encore pour moi qui est un revenu
minimum quand on n'a plus rien ça ne me
choque
je veux dire que là encore dans quelle
société voulons vivre c'est pas c'est
pas la société meilleure gagneur
vainqueur comme si jamais en mettant un
genou à terre
j'assume le rsa je moi ça me quand on a
tout perdu et qu'on a un minimum
franchement je pense que c'est un mec de
civilisation et qu'il faut pas jeter le
bébé avec l'eau du bain
la vérité de tout cela c'est que y
compris martin hirsch il voulait en
faire une affaire de lutte contre la
pauvreté est pas une affaire de
réinsertion le désaccord qu'on peut
avoir
n'est pas sur le principe d'une
allocation de subsistance
il est sur le sens que l'on donne au
travail moi je pense qu'on vit debout
quand on vit de son travail et qu'on vit
coucher quand on vide son revenu
l'assistance voilà là la différence
pendant entre nous c'est pas du tout
faut-il un rsa ou pas est-ce que je me
fais comprendre par donc prendre du
temps pour ça mais c'est très important
qui ait pas d'ambiguïté nous nous sommes
tous d'accord avec un revenu
d'assistance mais le revenu assistance
pour la gauche c'est une fin en soi
pour nous ce n'est qu'une étape parce
que on ne peut vivre qu'en travaillant
et on peut pas tout savoir un travail
marchand on peut pas tout savoir un
travail même je parlais des
schizophrènes gravité d'un d'une
bipolarité
certains peuvent travailler pas tous
mais alors si on peut pas travailler on
doit avoir une formation et si on peut
pas avoir de formation et pas de travail
on doit avoir une occupation au service
de la société
en tout cas personne ne peut considérer
qu'on peut avoir droit à une assistance
sans se donner du mal
voilà le message qu'est le dos
de là et c'est ça la différence
l'assistance s'est pas un droit c'est
pas une finalité
ses table au fond notre politique
sociale est entre deux principes que
jamais un seul de nos compatriotes ne
perde un centime
quand il passe de l'assistance au
travail et que jamais un seul de nos
compatriotes puissent bénéficier d'une
assistance change donné le mal d'avoir
un emploi une formation ou une
occupation s'il ne peut pas avoir un
emploi une formation
voilà le principe que nous pesons et
c'est la raison pour laquelle la
sanction c'est qu'on supprime les
allocations quand on n'accepte pas les
obligations qu'ils font avec cette
rémunération
alors là dedans ça pose deux autres
questions la question des étrangers et
qui est bien sûr importante faut pas
votre langue de bois un étranger qui vit
en france et qui cotisent il serait
scandaleux qu'il n'ait pas le droit à
l'allocation est ce que je me fais
comprendre parce que la location
la contrepartie d'une cotisation on peut
pas demander à quelqu'un paie une
cotisation
et puis lui dire la location tu l'as pas
par parenthèse ce qui vaut pour les
étrangers vaut pour la politique
familiale dont je rappelle que les
cotisations sont déplafonné en revanche
ce qu'on appelle les allocations non
contributives
je le dis comme je le pense un étranger
devrait passer au moins cinq ans en
france avant de pouvoir bénéficier d'une
allocation non contributives sinon c'est
un effet d'aubaine
je voudrais d'ailleurs chéri qu'on
couple se ce délai de cinq ans de
résidence par au moins un au travail un
an de travail au moins cinq ans deux
régions sont enfin je voudrais dire
d'ailleurs si éric mais le premier parlé
de ça je crois qu'il faut tenir dans le
contexte budgétaire d'aujourd'hui nous
ne pouvons pas financer l'allocation
médicale d'état gratuitement pour des
gens qui paient pas de cotisations ça
n'a pas de sens
remplaçons le par un système qui serait
très simple si un étranger sur le
territoire et qu'il est en situation
d'urgence médicale naturellement il faut
lui porter secours
ça va de soi mais y'a pas besoin d'avoir
un système une allocation un système
prévu
on peut s'inscrire avant tout ceci n'a
pas de sens alors vrai dernier beau mais
c'est pour conclure pour cliquer sur
quelque chose auquel je tiens c'est la
sphère de la famille françois hollande
depuis 2012 après lever 4 milliards
d'euros sur les familles et au fond ça a
été sa seule politique efficace puisque
grâce à cet effort sans précédent jamais
le nombre de naissances n'a été aussi
nos peu nombreuses depuis 1999 françois
hollande a voulu détruire la politique
familiale française il a réussi il faut
avoir l'honnêteté de le reconnaître
c'est absolument un triomphe
nous avons une baisse de 2,3 pour cent
des naissances par rapport à l'année
dernière n'a jamais fait si mal
depuis 1999 il a réussi cette partie de
ce bilan doit lui revenir comme comme il
se doit
il y avait donc une politique familiale
qui fonctionnait qui faisait
l'admiration de tous même les russes
s'en était inspiré puisqu'il perdait
jusqu'à 600 mille personnes par an
c'était un véritable drame quotient
familial plafonnement en toutes sortes
il faut revenir à la politique familiale
que nous avons connue pour redonner une
visibilité aux familles et je veux
redire y compris contre certains de mes
amis m'ont absolue opposition à la
fiscalisation des allocations familiales
la famille et la politique familiale
n'est pas une politique de
redistribution de revenus
elle est une politique qui permet de
dire aux familles si vous passez de un
enfant 1 2 baissez pas de niveau de vie
si vous passez 2 3 vous baissez pas divo
dit on prête pour on peut être content
mais on ne fait pas de la redistribution
de revenus avec la politique familiale
il ya pour ça un impôt sur le revenu il
ya pour ça une cg l'un est progressive
l'autre et est proportionnel non la
politique familiale
elle est essentielle bien sûr nous
serons amenés à diminuer le pourcentage
de remboursement des dépenses
d'assurance maladie puisque nous
passerons de 76 73
ces deux milliards le point mais juré
comme vous rendre attentifs au fait que
même à 73%
nous serons encore le système qui
embauchent le bio sur les affections de
longue durée 1 % d'efficacité en plus et
c'est un milliard d'économies
donc ceux d'entre nous qui ne voudront
pas suivre le parcours de prévention et
les conseils de santé publique de nos
médecins et ne pourront pas prétendre
avoir le remboursement à 100% définitif
de leur affection
ça s'appelle une société de
responsabilité en un mot on est des
humanistes
on laisse tomber personne mais on croit
la responsabilité donc qu'on met chacun
devant ses responsabilités quand on
souffre et qu'on n'y est pour rien la
société la solidaire
si on est irresponsable la société ne
doit pas payer pour vous je vous
remercie tous d'avoir bien voulu passer
ce temps sur cette convention n'est
simple